you wrote the script and you're coming
off of school days how the hell did you
get this movie made well it was a
different time all right I'll take this
it's it was a different time and as
spike has been quoted in the press and I
think it's true I doubt that
do the right thing would be made by any
studio today
maybe Fox Searchlight for very little
money many student yeah but by big
studio no just because the business has
changed it's not the it's not you know
the subject matter it's it's the
business today is all about you know
sequels and all that stuff but it wasn't
in those days so we could make it this
one this script Sean Daniel who's
somewhere here in the audience
Sean can you stand up please yeah so on
you should take a bow wherever you are
there it is
tell his title tell his title Tom Tillis
is hello it is Sam kid here
Sam Sam here why Shawn when I was
chairman of Universal Shawn was a
president production I had seen I had
not seen school days but I had seen
she's got to have it and I thought it
was a remarkable movie but Shawn came to
me and said I think we can get spikes
new script and I said what's it about he
said it's about race I said okay let's
read it and we read it and you know it's
powerful and it was was it an easy call
no but it was really good
and you know the deal that we made with
spike spike hadn't had the best
experience on school days at Columbia
and I'm still and what he was most
concerned about you know was no
interference by the studio and and that
we support the movie you know with
marketing when and when it came out and
so we made a deal
basic it was a really easy deal I said
okay you can have six million dollars to
make this movie not a penny more
of course he talked me into another five
hundred thousand dollars because he's a
very good negotiator and so it was made
for six and a half and if you do that
it's yours do them make the movie you
want to make and we'll support it and
basically that's what he did and that's
what we did and how did that's how it
got made I don't think I think think we
all knew it was gonna be good and maybe
a little controversial but I don't think
any of us knew 25 years later that we'd
be sitting here you know celebrating it
is one of the great movies and I like to
take this moment because I've said it in
the
I once ate in front of you everybody
here Tom Pollock is the unsung hero of
this film because I know there are a lot
of new head's new Jack's here but you
weren't around when the stone came out
but it started at the world premiere and
can where there was a sick with the
press who do not want this film to come
out for writing reviews saying it's
Dilma's and cause black people to run
amok that this movie would cause race
riots whatever that is as if a movie is
it was a movie that could cause a race
riot and and here's a thing though which
a lot of you don't you don't remember
Tom Pollock had done a film called Last
Temptation of Christ before this and Tom
he went through the wringer on that one
he had to get he had bodyguards
so was he could have easily said spike I
can't do this again but he didn't do
that he stood behind the film instead
we're putting it out
thank thank you spike it's thank you
guys the truth share the truth it's in
fact we showed it in Cannon May it
didn't win [ __ ] one but Steven
Soderbergh film won that year but the
press did start writing all these things
so of course what did we do we move the
release date up so we could take
advantage of all that controversy so so
he came out earlier in the summer but he
opened up his idea was to open up the
same day as Batman I saw him that was
sudeerneer idea people to get this
wheeled June 30th 1989 we opened the
same day as Batman more Jack Nicholson
Michael Keaton Prince did the music same
day we start the program counter program
and we still did really well this the
movie did the movie did financially much
better than I actually thought it would
I it's you know some movies you make
thinking you're gonna make a lot of
money and then other movies you make
because you think they're gonna be
really good and that this was the latter
but it turned out to be a profitable
movie and it's because it managed to
manage to touch record